[Music]
in freak accident news that's my most
scared way to die
like that's like my biggest fear a guy
with three legs shits himself like a
death one okay didn't tell me the
details submitted by Ken Bob I don't
like it means either President of
Somalia Somalia is my country sorry of
Joe Mallya ken bob president drew Mallya
president of the of the golf club he for
all yeah there's another golf klutz a
big deal are we free men dolls is one of
the top sports they're three members
yeah the Jamali Golf Club
oh of course Tom say thank you because
we're friends we get top quality like
presidential lean everything nepotism at
its finest honor driver from my golf
cart you get whatever you want I'm
Secretary of Energy of Jamal Ian there's
a lot of blackouts and brownouts
it's a cushy gig brown as pin he think
it's a lot of electrical problems ok
those rolling blackouts he's busy
writing a movie it's okay
a woman is suing the Houston Astros for
1 million dollars after being injured by
a t-shirt cannon would you like front
row what did you just do but he did like
her teeth no she got beaned with that
[ __ ]
she broke her nose what happened so this
chick her name is Jennifer she is from
Texas
yeehaw Texas so she's filing a suit
against the Astros claiming that the
t-shirt cannon that was fired into the
grant a crowd irreparably injured her
left index finger Wow this chick is bald
I love this so when she was trying to
catch it it just went like that yeah so
then that that that's the mascot
orbit launched a t-shirt from close
range and so I met it smashed into her
hand in the fractured her finger well
she was the dumb as I try to catch it
right I mean I mean
she's asking for a million dollars in
damages a million because if she was
just sitting and like eating her hot dog
and a [ __ ] t-shirt just wearing Wow
like that and then she [ __ ] wit had
whiplash or it's like a broker chin or
something that's like that makes sense
it doesn't make sense though it's like
when they shoot when they hit home runs
the balls flying at them meaning they
don't sue for that [ __ ] right so she had
two surgeries I want to see the damn two
how fast is a t-shirt cannon go it's
like [ __ ] 80 miles an hour sure but
that would suck to not be able to move
your hand the same way that you're used
to moving your hands index you can't
masturbate ever the same again yeah I do
left hand because it used to feel like a
stranger was doing it but then I got
used to it feels regularly now right
hand feels like a stranger just they
both feel like just me now got it
usually have him do know she doesn't
like fingers though she hates finger
stuff and it takes them forever after
like you know like like now it's up and
down it takes me forever because I'm
because I'm completely in that well
because it's like did they get the
precious quads me I [ __ ] did it
you're good with your tongue thank you
that's what matters
that's all that matters exactly it is
all that matters the fingers like I'd
rather have you been good at your tongue
your fingers but who wants a high school
[ __ ] finger bang no thanks want to do
it looks hard and you used to just nail
this it's like you need to get the
pressure just right and then keep it
that pressure as you're moving don't
lighten the pressure and don't go harder
go in the [ __ ] hurt yes but if you
don't know what the pressure is you
don't know how to spin so when I go
right there that pressure right there
then you keep it there what's the
pressure what's the pressure tell me
like you squeeze an avocado well it's
not like that you have to be doing it
and then I go right there and then you
keep it there I just move like this just
very little subtle movements like this
like
this but I don't but we don't need to do
finger stuff we don't do fingers inside
now no fingers gonna say because
fingernails are gross and dirty yeah
exactly see that that's so there there's
the real thing
Niki never had to show me how to do it
to her because she never wanted that
[ __ ] so it's all tongue action hell I
just get a vibrator no cuz then you over
stimulate the [ __ ] and then your dick
is worthless yes they're gonna learn
that they don't need us anymore and [ __ ]
that
Jessica uses me as a dildo yeah okay
what does that mean some girls stuff
they leave the date they leave like a
dildo inside the vagina cuz they like to
feel filled up while they do the anal
stimulate on top actually pretty dope I
like it because the push you start
shakin like a washing machine what do
you mean yeah if you're just staying in
they're not moved no no you could pop a
little but sometimes it's it's it's cool
because like I'm about to burst anyway
so I need to chill out so I'm just
sitting there like this that sounds hot
as [ __ ] dude the way that you're
chilling oh it's all happening
internally I wish you were wearing a
Hawaiian shirt with a [ __ ] white on
your nose where you do that anyway oh
yeah finger I wouldn't be able to master
it the same if I that I had to learn a
left hand out of necessity as well
that's worth suing you're just like yeah
dude he's like looking at his old
friends cuz you gotta click this is back
in a day that's that's all I learned
back in the day when you're in the
garage with the [ __ ] library slides I
could have dude the right hand with the
mouse it was too confusing everything
was doing the opposite thing like this
that's true I usually do photos I used
to do literati qey and read the story
wait what is that one no they're not
romance no you could pick different
categories oh and it's still pretty hot
but basically it's a story and like my
imagination was better than the pictures
that I could find oh dude I love
watching the chick from incredible
getting [ __ ] shitty I wanted to hold
it I tried to hold my people make fanfic
was like that yeah oh yeah oh yeah we're
cartoons it's even weirder cuz all tall
big dicks on these like cutesy animals
and it's like the [ __ ] are you people
they like Clarisse when you guys watch
porn do you take you like a couple
videos or like a lot of videos or it's
like no but I do skip to the part where
the guys are about to [ __ ] you skip to
the part where you try to synchronize
your come cuz I do that you try to come
with the guy or the girl sometimes if
there's a squirt video and that's pretty
nice if you can do at the same time the
girls squirting dude so I ever really
close and then the guy comes to be like
oh no you know what I [ __ ] hate is
when they cut to the guy's face when
he's right about it inaudible they stop
doing that I haven't seen that Hey but
that is an old night and you're like
yeah and then it's like right when
you're nutty guys faces you're like me
it's like a Beasley they look on the
guy's face is like he's on a motorcycle
with his helmet off the most wind
[ __ ] in his face nobody wants to see
a guy's face what not even the girls
want to see that I don't know but do you
like my face more than one I do it yeah
I think I have a pretty cute [ __ ] face
actually you like session tell you to
free
I'm telling on you look this is Jennifer
I just like thought she was masturbating
cuz she looks like she likes the zoo oh
yeah I forgot this is about suing yeah
oh [ __ ] she stick that in water it's all
bruised she [ __ ] slap it against but
I've not even deformed or anything it
kind of bruise bruised in there and all
this [ __ ] guarding [ __ ] I have a finger
look do you see this [ __ ] let me show
you this would you do this was going to
the gym so the first time I was going to
Hawaii with these guys I was like
alright first time in Hawaii I'm gonna
travel I'm gonna get pumped up so I went
to the gym I said alright we're going in
a week just do these sixty pounders and
I was doing these but I was pushing the
the dumbbells and I was laying down and
then when I got up to put it down the
dumbbell hit another dumbbell and then
my finger exploded at the [ __ ] gym
and it wasn't it the dumb bone and hit
my fingers just the pressure for the
dumbbell hitting the other dumbbell and
I have to go up there exploded and just
fractured and splitting just gave
somebody a [ __ ] and cut off their
dick yeah Oh seen a finger like that in
person during surgery I actually got to
assist in one of the surgeries and it
was this dude he shattered his middle
finger while moving a refrigerator yeah
and like I was holding it open you could
see all the bones they look like broken
glass yeah so for that injury how much
do you think is fair compensation if you
were able to get like some kind of help
for it from the gym with or the gym or
if that same accident happened at the at
the at the stadium this is his fault
and I've been like under a hundred key
or something that's more reasonable than
a million dollars to me as soon as you
gotta go hard because by the end of you
set up they settle yeah then that finish
they're selling 20k injuries you're more
likely to settle so she has to go high
to get to get like she said that she
approached them she initially
went to the Astros to ask for
compensation for her medical bills
because she paid $15,000 for her medical
bills
but then the team refused to help well I
walked up then that's when she was like
well I've never sued anyone in my life
it's just that I want like she deserves
compensation for mental anguish lots of
opportunity and loss of enjoyment of
life and like her medical cost I mean
that finger was holding her back from a
lot of things you know you want to learn
how to shoot guns with the left hand but
you know now that's like me dude I can't
put contacts with this finger into this
I use my middle finger now and do it but
it is just annoying to have to go to the
doctors and get surgeries and take time
out of your day and like you can't move
this hand and stuff like that I do agree
with her though if they work if they
even handle this [ __ ] right and they
treated me like [ __ ] I will go after
them with so much fire that's when you
come in with that mental anguish at the
amount the Boyar was probably like we
should start with I would have been like
you know what
Oh billions not enough 10 million go for
a girl take it huh yeah I feel their
pain
think I at least helped her out with the
insurance so the Astros said that they
do not agree with the allegations and
they said that they would not stop the
promotion of using the t-shirt launcher
things I love t-shirt cannons I think
they're hilarious now it's all that
people always go like this
anything get hit in the face I'll
[ __ ] love it there's someone's
catching you while holding a baby and
[ __ ] they throw the baby like yeah yeah
the best
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]